Jenny slate and Chris Evans make their  red carpet debut at the secret life of  pets premiere in New York but did not  pose for photos together et was the only  outlet to catch the cute couple  interacting on the green carpet Saturday  Chris stain incognito on his  girlfriend's big day says goodbye to the  actress before she chats with us we see  Chris is here supporting you today  what's so great about having him out  here for a special day like them I  haven't really has a very large premiere  before so it's nice having someone who  sort of knows how it goes and also  honestly we're just like both two  teenagers from Massachusetts so it kind  of feels like I got my dream seventh  grade boyfriend that is not so much you  got where did you guys meet did you guys  know each other from Massachusetts no we  didn't know each other growing up but we  grew up from about a half an hour from  each other and we've been friends for a  while and  you